right
are you good I am good I was waiting for
your cue flash point what's that man
you're gonna do a real interval quick
let's do it all right
three two one go for it flash point
bonus we are back back in the building a
lot of stuff going on how you doing oh
pretty good it's uh it's gonna be a
crazy morning because we got this I'm
chomping at the bit to go see a slightly
anticipated movie if you can't imagine
with that he's not in order right there
waiting for an ultimate compilation of
marvel yeah I'm in the right place you
know infinity was out there I'm just
blessed it you still here no they don't
have surely otherwise I'd be doing this
later very very appreciative there's a
flask way happy well we can't make it
too much of a Long Point at all I got a
couple hours we got some time to delve
in but yeah we'll try and try and make
it reasonable we got some good topics to
discuss this morning but on a sidebar I
know I probably shouldn't even be doing
that I know you guys are enjoying what's
coming sounds like there's a lot of good
things coming we've got a few things to
discuss but we had a big game drop in
about the last week or so both of us had
our ability to get our hands on it and
dabble into a little bit God of War I'm
talking about it man just a quick
rundown I'm probably 7 to 8 hours and
and I'm taking my time like exploring
every side path kind of go wandering
around and everything so our it's living
up I mean I don't want to say too much I
don't know like obviously give any
spoilers but you see it getting crazy
reviews people saying it's like you know
one of their best games they played in a
long time
and so far so good and I'm not even that
far in yeah I would have to agree I'm
again maybe a little bit before you
something five six hours and same thing
taking my time
do my thing and it just was me every
little thing you know and um again it's
very early you know I know there's still
a lot of game but there's some game that
when you play them you like there's a
certain part of me you both talked about
and I'm like yeah you get to the
knock-knock sequence me back when you
get to that this is the game starts off
with the strangers you know and it's
just wow yeah like there will be no
spoilers but the game starts to tone off
really early and what they're doing
right now with Sandy what it says oh man
it's it's just it's Wow Wow
when join the rise and join round that's
good stuff hats off to that studio and
it's one of those moments I don't want
to say this for any game and pretty much
anybody in the world of entertainment
when something amazing comes out and
it's pretty much in the level of
greatness mm-hmm it's really cool to see
everyone from every walk of gaming and
things like that unanimously yes give
cheers and praise to this game and it's
be it you know the xbox president you
see Bungie shutting it out you see
everybody from everywhere being hey you
guys we like we appreciate what you've
done you have done an amazing job thank
you and that's it no simple no caveats
no nothing just hats off to an amazing
piece of work absolutely that's what
it's about man is he a shout out to all
you know even like you said Microsoft
even the other I believe the wasn't
guerilla games for horizon zero dawn and
you know it isn't really cool and it's
good to see you know greatness
recognized you know and like I said so
far so good I have my verdict you know
once that thing is completed but I'm
actually take my time with it man I'm
really enjoying it so it's just good
like filler before you know suppose a
DLC that we don't be talking about yes
just take the time guys if you do play
that game which I highly highly
recommend enjoy the little pieces don't
speed through it don't skip over the
stuff look at the details and just watch
and it's something you can't not watch
because there are no cutscenes the skip
you're in the mix cinematography sounds
a weird basically the way the game is
shot the way the cameras positioned
you're in it the whole time if you were
able to stay awake for like 36 hours and
play it straight it would be one
continuous story and I think it's a cool
thing I know other things may have done
it but just the way it's presented is
really well done so I had to get that
out away gonna be looking forward to
more that one for sure but you guys came
here for destiny so let's jump in and
see what we've got
Tuesday slightly a big day right we get
the warmind reveal stream so multiple
sets of people on there some from
Vicarious Visions who seems to be
working kind of hand-in-hand with bungee
it sounds like more so there are the
ones who developed a PC port but I think
they're just kind of in the mix with
them now co-developing this thing which
is really cool
and to get you guys started I guess the
way a Bungie stream sometimes does it
we've got the reveal archive so this is
it but we're just gonna start with the
trailer real fast you guys can get a
feel for what is coming though they
kicked it up in style and whoever puts
those trailers together for destiny
tough a damn good job walking teams
always late like always it's gonna be
like tingles by the time I'm done
watching whatever I'm watching sell it
to the market today always knocking out
the part yeah so they had people from
Vicarious Visions so those were a couple
leads there then they had a tour of a
Hello spaceman which we'll get to talk
about that a little bit and then they
had some
I had Kevin Gaines and Cosmo on talking
about crucible so they had a lot of guys
on there john was new ski Josh Hamrick
so so much stuff in this thing guys when
you see on Twitter it's gonna be like
3700 words feel like I need to sit down
it was crazy but the talk in first big
point we got exotics
who's huge this is where things get idea
okay so as you guys know most you guys
probably have most of the exotics
already if not all of them they've been
handed out fairly quickly and they
actually flat out address that they say
oh right here many players if not all of
the have most if not all of the non
Quest exotics and the quests you guys
probably knocked out as well and they
don't want to make players where you're
in exotics but they've been trying to
find a way to make exotics literally
exotic again make the acquisition feel
good make the upgrading feel good and
the way the weapon feels should be
unique and exotic so steps in the right
direction so what are they doing sir
this is exotic master works man this
whole bit should I touch right into the
the catalyst yeah just jump right in all
right here I mean pretty much you know
as the Bob is explaining you know that
it will be one exact mask work per
exotic weapon and in order to bring the
mass with process it's not gonna be just
how it was with the legendary so pretty
much what they're gonna do you're gonna
have to find this exotic master work
catalyst and when inspecting the exotic
there'll be a hint which act which kind
of gives you the what activity that will
grant the catalyst for that weapon and
it says not all master works exact max
will have the same drop rates some
exotic max where weapons are guaranteed
after certain amount of engagement or
others are R&G so this is pretty cool
yeah this is pretty cool and the thing
about it it actually gives me shades of
exotic bounties yep and just a whole you
know mystery behind it and one thing
about it which is cool is that also it's
going to
to unlock an additional perk set you
know a perk for the exotic to make it
even more powerful so not only do we
have the exotic tuning that's already
happening with these exotics that we
already have right now we're gonna also
have this Maxwell catalyst as something
to grind for and continue on for and I
think like this is pretty pretty cool
what's your feeling on it so far so far
from what I've heard I like that you
don't have to go get a new exotic and
hopefully it's gonna be a masterwork or
it's gonna take you know ten cores and
it's gonna make us blow through that
again either I like that it's different
because Korres for legendaries their
standard currency work on those on your
basic stuff that's fine but if you're
gonna make exotics unique you had to do
in a different way and I think this is a
great start so the fact that you have
different ways for different guns to
unlock the catalyst to get started that
alone is cool so you can see cold heart
it says found in strikes against the
most challenging opponents yes most
people are assuming either their heroics
or maybe bosses on strikes or just
nightfalls in general but you can kind
of get away but there's think we're not
telling you guys now people are gonna
figure this out this is what we wanted
we wanted things for the community to
figure out this is the guys build
together when there's YouTube videos
exploding when there's ready to saying
hey here's the threat of what how what
are all the catalysts for your exotics
people are looking people are diving in
it's a reason to take your gun and the
nice thing is the catalyst changes some
of these weapons yes essentially there's
only two I've heard there's only two
I've heard so those the only two I know
of like wing vigilance wing and crimson
are the two i've heard of what it is yes
so we'll get to those here in a second
but the idea is they're all different
exotics already good they're all getting
buffs all right if you guys have seen
some of the stuff with regards to rat
king when you're in a group and when you
it's 2 to 3 it's reloaded you don't even
have to have it out just equipped yeah
it's full auto now you've got graviton
Lance with the two-shot with the
portable prime like mercs got like
little balls going on so many things
they showed more with
card late we'll get to some of these
other changes in a bit but yeah all the
exotics are getting buffed and this is
gonna take them literally to a different
level so big time I think this is gonna
be something that's gonna be fun and
really make this is what I asked and
preached it before make it a hard
decision
what's exotic do I want to run mm-hmm
this I think is gonna hopefully give
people options of play styles and
alternatives and definitely as well
you're still gonna get the orbs so now
you can use it as well in PvE for
strikes
max were kind of orbiting continue using
is just like it's just good across the
board so you got the orb generation like
the legendaries we've got new perks for
these things it's a challenge to get
them they're different different places
some are orangey summertime based like I
mean that's that's the type of stuff
this is these setting up befall the sea
these are the things I wanted to see
this is huge I want a gentleman real
quick because um this is I got we've
been ripping them let's be honest for a
couple of months and this is something
that was completely unexpected to be
honest I didn't know how he would handle
exotic masterworks are very curious
about this update to see how I would be
approached and what's doable body is
they're not making us have to get the
exotic again you know and kind of like
trash the existing one
you keep it but you have to do setting
activities and I was having this
discussion when I got about two recently
and you know his concern was hey I don't
want to do a lot of life you don't
random orangey I don't know what to do
but I said here's the thing you know
like like you said he bought it's like a
lot of this kind of stuff this mystery
that was kind of indie one that's
missing in d2 which is where it
galvanizes to compute community you're
trying to figure out where to go what
exactly to do you know I'm saying for
each you know exotic catalyst that to me
it's very cool you know I miss those
days of like okay you got that exotic
bone what you know do a crucible
activity or do whatever you're trying to
figure out specifically where to go
where to do it at what triggers it that
kind of stuff is really really cool and
then the fact that they're even going
the extra mile like we said we know a
vigilance when it supposed to be full
auto is
supposed to be the ultimate catalyst
unlock perk in addition to the stat
boost because if you look at the
pictures of cold heart right now look at
that stability right see their stability
you see now early low-speed jump up so
not only are you getting the stat boost
not only are you getting the orb
generation then there will be a double /
like that is really cool so that exotic
becomes your exotic right you you worked
hard and what I like is it forces you to
really play with something you love and
master it you know so just I love this
this is I really don't want to
understate how much I love this change
right this is really good unexpected
very hype to be honest
low-key this is probably one of the most
things if excited for and the whole deal
seal it's cool don't get me wrong but
I'm really excited for this no I mean
that's huge as you said you got stats
you've got the reason to grind and they
they did it right they're not like hey
go do public events get your master
record from whatever and then put them
into whatever exotics play with the
weapon you want to upgrade and use it to
get better you're gonna have to spend
some time with each gun just to use it
you're not gonna be like hey I just want
to go through and get enough of these
cores and drop some cores into those so
I just know I have the master works I
want and then they're just in my outfit
or II you gotta spend some time with it
and that's that's how if you're gonna
have a master of anything you need to
spend some time with it to master it to
do 79 in the chat man we got to get you
but they get they run it they run a cool
show he wants as it's called our talk
how it going man these guys are really
hardcore destiny love what they're doing
over shoutout to a short pause my boy
Pete load up in the do 79 is in the chat
yeah man we're excited excited about
these master works if you don't hear it
already in real life so going down a
little lower so we've got some details
about the exotics and they said there's
gonna be plenty of questions so let's
answer a few those before we get going
so they said to get a head of the
questions I said exotic master work
pursuits only need to be what done once
for a count
grinding it all the time I mean you can
move the weapons per count so it makes
sense through master work process do
people get drops of an exotic via
whatever they will basically you'll pick
them up at the same master work State so
for some reason if you're on a different
character and you pick one up and you're
like hey I have two of these you can you
know continue on with the next one it
seems kind of minor but it's still there
so the exotic master work process takes
fully place in the weapon screens and no
inventory use anything like that so
that's a good thing
not all exotic master works will be
available immediately now this is the
one I was kind of wondering about I
wonder how many they're gonna have are
they gonna duel em out like every couple
of weeks is like a little teaser or I
mean so then you're just gonna have lo
que here's these three everybody knows
how to get them here's another three
like I'm I kind of wish it was a lot so
it's just this like info-dump of like
everybody it's like hey I'm gonna pick
this one first this person picks this
what it was a little more variety if
there's like five then and I know
there's any more than that but I want it
I would like to have seen it to be
almost all of them maybe it won't be the
new exotics maybe it won't be
masterworks yet maybe maybe yeah it
could be it - it may be maybe it's uh
restricted to the the initial ones you
know first the initial set that we
already know of that we already have and
the tower hasn't had a chance to get oh
and figure out their blueprint they'll
just go oh yeah that's a good question
because I wonder if not if they
reintroducing the source regime right
well the suros have it at you know at
dandy at launch what would it be
something that's a you know what would
that one be for you what would be your
exotic masterwork hope that's what I was
saying because it sources what is it up
zoomed in fire calls you know double
more damage right yeah it was like focus
fire so it's slower but more damage and
then or was a little quicker out of
sights but you also have the chance to
get some help but didn't they'd also
have um what's the perk where the bottom
half of the magazine also now I didn't
see that part of the perk in it I'm
assuming it should have it
I have no idea it may not be exactly the
same but yeah that's hard man cuz
service is so good as it is you know
with that they got the you know the fire
rate what could they I mean then it also
remembers oh he'll tink tink tink tink
there's the sound when I think it's
beast like oh man vanilla d1 I think so
but I don't know what they would add to
that as far as like a catalyst part yeah
so there are two that I've heard of so
the two that we know of as you said
pendulum swing is one you already said
that one going full auto it's got to do
monster yeah it's out to do it he said
full auto vigilance alright please in
the competition in the crucible and if
so you're in recent range to start it on
about their belly button by the time to
get to their head they're done like God
just so much
so that's crazy and then crimson which
definitely gonna need a little rework so
we'll see what they do with that one but
it's gonna be a hundred range Wow
so a hand cannon with max like full
range on that one
Wow so yeah that little tap may get some
written may get a little uh a little
more harder to tag down even if you're
using a scout rifle apparently gonna be
a hand cannon so that's kind of nuts
well we wanted exacts to feel exactly
now ya know I want them I want to be
like cool crap which one do I pick and
that's the whole point
that's literally the point if they're
all to a point of now some are still
gonna be better that's fine but if some
fits certain play styles which we'll get
to some other ones that do as well they
have certain benefits for certain
situations there's some that just felt
pretty man most of the time and now
we've got some alternative so this will
be good well come down here we've got
John wise new ski so they got more
exotic kind of previews basically so we
had already seen strum and Sturm and
Drang
we saw very impressive yeah so that's
the one where if you use the Drang
sidearm get the kills and you can start
stacking bullets and your hand cannon
that overloads it up to 20 I think it
starts with like 12 each bullet above
the base that you start stacking into it
and as you can do it as long as you
don't die you can stack up to 20 in
there so you could have six seven eight
shots I can't quite remember the right
amount but are doing double damage of a
normal hand cannon shot you can two-shot
with that thing oh if you can have like
three people that you can to shot if you
can stay alive that's gonna take some
skill but that's the skill I mean that's
the cool things that we get to start
watching again that's where it's fun to
be entertained by people at that ultra
high skill level in those competitive
matches like okay they got the whole
sidearm kills got a couple cider and
he's switching over he's always gonna go
finish the team oh he does the cover you
can see those like start trying to get
there you can see those moments getting
a little better so that one's cool and
so we got some new ones so we got
tractor cannon hard lighting L'Oreal
isn't a Playstation one that's a cannon
so shout out to destiny Gary he is a
happy man right now he doesn't love that
he likes to troll with it so I'll show
you guys here real quick basically in
the video you'll see he's got the
tractor cannon he jumps up now when he
shoots him with a tractor cannon and
what it doesn't show he's doing so much
damage in there basically the idea is
you can see those shots on screen it's
like a 169 with a sidearm everyone's
creating basically what it does is it
tractor cannon for one applies
suppression now for bosses it may not
count for basically most enemies and for
crucible suppression works for you can't
use your abilities it's rough so I mean
obviously a pretty but it's also gonna
make you vulnerable to avoid damage so
you're significantly more weak to avoid
damage so if you have a void cinch on a
nightfall for example and you bring in
tractor cannon you gotta be that
risk/reward come in and if you're with a
team one of you guys runs that tractor
can and runs in there fly by Bam shoot
him somebody drops two rockets in there
or a nova bomb
you're gonna start melting bosses this
is this is where that's the play of a
team like blazing out what weapons
you're gonna have them avoid cinch are
we gonna like is it worth that just made
void a whole different animal oh
absolutely absolutely because I'm only
not even think about that I'm also
thinking about synergy for my void lock
with certain things as well because I'm
the exotic I believe was it the exotic
was it the UM what's that one Nazareth
what another X and one of those that's
everything boy right yeah yeah man so
I'm just thinking of like tremendous
energy all around this thing is really
gonna be a great debuff for bosses and
I'm curious about because we know it has
that suppression effect right so I'm
curious that in PvP will that operate
like the old you know Titan fun police
you're gonna blast them off and they're
getting ready to do it they can't just
like turn around a throw a grenade or
they're shut down on ability there's a
kind of limp mode for a little while
nothing love it that that took that may
track that that's great utility you know
for a weapon for the most part let's be
honest like Santa's killings a joke
happening like it was it it was fun but
did you have a lot of purpose like I'm
not gonna go do a boss rush with it or
anything like that there's no way I'm
gonna get worked so this is and these
are the types of things as we said a
situational change where if you have you
want to go void on and I don't even know
what the modifiers are gonna be on
heroic strikes but say they do throw
some void stuff in there okay go grab a
tractor cannon let's do it guys yep one
have it at least in your inventory on
strikes you can switch it out since
you've got it somebody else so please
got void and get rolling so he's out the
car box or the chat he's like he's gonna
rip through bosses with coordinated fire
teams absolutely if you had to nova
bombs and then on top of that one
tractor 1 traductor to Noah at the same
time you want to talk about melting the
boss oh yeah that's gotta hurt tether
down the only you go god with the tether
throw shadow grenade shoot the tractor
cannon to nova bombs that boss is done
that
just tired of checking out guys it's too
much I got a call in today I got a call
in Thanos this is too much for me so of
Avengers their little beast mode action
[Music]
next we come to hard light now it's
actually not terrible in the first place
it's got no range drop off basically
it's a laser light show it's fun to
watch but they wanted to give it more a
little more oomph so first it's gonna
work the way borealis does for the
damage types which ain't just our lights
should have had for the longest let's
switch those abilities could you no no I
mean it's good it's just like the whole
go in switch it on the weapon thing come
back out it's just like no you're gonna
have one that does all three and you had
it on one yes this is perfect yeah he'll
the bounce off the walls is pretty but
it's really hard to hit people you can
I've done it jokingly but now it's gonna
be some scale shows yes bouncing bullets
do double damage that's that's it what
do you got yeah I mean that listen we
all mean it was always to me the thing
you know the techno light Shogun like it
was cool you know what it could do it
look good but was it really functionally
effective the Ricochet not really I mean
I remember sleeper actually being
something that can actually kill
yourself with but now if they're
doubling ricochet bullet damage you can
actually do some work with this
theoretically right so um yeah man I'm
excited I mean this to me be able to
hold down a real Oh button switch my
elements on the fly now you've added
complete functionality to this gun like
on the fly night and you sort of clip
they're going back and forth he's going
sole avoid our back that's what I'm
talking about just add utility back with
that gun make it easy just how they do
with borealis I'm good man yeah so it
goes here switch this over to arc for
the harpies starts to blast them and
still just crushing it and then switches
over here to avoid meltdown the minutes
are just three in a row I'm like that
gun feels exotic just right there for
use of the fact that you can hit all
three shields I mean so because
if I'm gonna go bring an exotic into PvE
and the other thing this stacks with now
with those shield types mattering even
more yeah because it was 3x damage if
you match the right shield to us with
energy and one of kinetic this thing
just became PvE powerful this is
notified I'm thinking about heroic calm
which cause the most high restore work
ones as well of inventors mm-hmm yep I
mean you would ask a good question
though do something he says wonder if we
can switch elements on prestige
nightfalls
I would assume so because the Lord yeah
that's a gun not the element type right
you just locked into the hard light but
you still should be able to switch the
element cuz that's a feature of heart
light that you're locked into right yeah
it's not yeah I would assume so too
yeah if not then it damn sure should be
so yes yeah so I mean that was pretty
cool and as you say in prestige is like
the perfect spot what if it's that point
where you have Centurions coming out on
one side but you gotta Marquis later on
you want to be able to be effective on
both well how are like just become
alright for your PlayStation users let
me tune out either Simon your boat guys
can join in the Xbox paid the
PlayStation getting all these great guns
and strikes okay I gotta say the strike
on PlayStation 4 I don't miss it yeah
that's true I did hear that yeah you're
gonna be like me I'm in the boss fights
ok it's so I tend to be a little bit as
well to kind of okay okay okay how old
am i okay
but no Chris old maps have been they've
been okay it's more just the fact that
adds a little more variety that's
basically all they might may not be the
favorite but if it's one that just
doesn't come up that often you get a
little more through your rotation and
that's all I wish so that's the only
reason like for the crucible maps is
just variety but borealis is a sniper
I feel if you're not on PlayStation and
it works similar to hardlight where if
you hold down reload you switch the
damage types of that you're doing but
now you're do now it's gonna work a
little bit differently you want to cover
what's going on with this one I mean
just from what I remember it was more of
a like they're basically up in damage
right so pretty much just hit it real
quick
it's um yeah basically have the
exchanging utility that come you can
match the shield but for PvE
they want to give a little bit more of a
perk so that you know pretty much it's
gonna is it like doubling damage you're
doubling damages snipe around yes that's
a one-hit kill to the body so you got
reload it's pretty rare to pull off
across fair amount of predictive
awareness but we had it happen
organically a few times so that's
actually pretty cool you know because if
you're double damaging into the next
reload or damage type swap that's pretty
beneficial and gives more you know
powerful functionalities in it to the
sniper gun so I mean I think that's dope
what do you feel about it I mean it's
got it's got a very high skill ceiling
which rie need more more of that so in
PvP the idea is very interesting if
somebody's and they're super and you can
pop them with us like a shot of the
right type and they said it doesn't
happen that often but if you get double
damage out of anything on a sniper
that's a body shot that's a one kill
body shot so that one's actually pretty
cool but I think it's gonna be hard to
do but if somebody some of those awesome
snipers came back like it was I cannot
remember the two guys the crafty Hovey
like some of those awesome snipers came
back to use this one and they could
actually put it together and we say no
we say and then on the other side in PvE
if you break the proper enemy she'll die
if you're doing double damage so if you
can you know plane it right where you're
like okay I'm gonna pop an enemy shield
turn on the boss or double damage well
you guys go do this let me pop a shield
go get double damage headshots on a boss
start melting them down even more too so
and if you're running void hey somebody
throw trying they're talking about
synergy I mean I just like the idea that
we're gonna have more options so they're
making some of these more powerful this
one seems a little on the high skilled
not quite as frequently
happen side it's gonna be but as not all
of us have it you know you guys can
enjoy it for now at PlayStation and if I
jump on there it's fine I got it on
PlayStation but I never used it so god
let me ask you a quick question now that
we're on this whole sniper kick what do
you think they add for buff to Darcy hmm
just thinking about little old Darcy got
the range you've got the highlighting
it's pretty much just I mean it's a
sniper but but they remember they're
going to buff every exotic weapon so
this is a really we're gonna not do is
like Wardenclyffe marissa why were they
gonna touch the minigun I think a Chris
gets left alone right a curious gets
left alone what's the minigun sweet risk
runner no sweet business is the one I
was talking about almost be all I can't
remember somewhere it's on an old [ __ ]
it's like it's gonna old WAP yeah
but the multi-tool may be fun but yeah I
think Darcy is gonna get a change for
sure and I'm like no I really I'm just
thinking about it like what could they
do it's gonna be very interested to see
let's give them credit they coming up
with really cool stuff so far they've
been unique I'm definitely kind of
digging it so far what I'd like is would
you like uh something for borealis if
you're like aim down sights like make it
give it some perks that make a PvP
sniper maybe for aim down sights for a
while locked on ahead hang on to it for
like three or four seconds line hit
belonga you're like tracked on ahead you
know risk reward the more your damage
gets built up or something cuz you
highlight the enemies you've got the
range yeah I don't know I mean that'd be
something different but I mean that's
just me here on the spot but I have no
clue at all I mean we know it's not like
one of the higher damage archetypes
so I'll just thinking maybe like you
said even they do some type of slight
precision damage buff so make it like a
high skill weapon or you know maybe add
like an old-school I know this might be
really okay
I'd like an old-school triple tap on it
I'm very curious about what they do it
does it cuz it holds a lot you know we
cooled actually it was no twenty now I
think total yes I want to Nikolas it's
like it's crazy but I miss my Irene
Irene RR for what triple taboo that was
my sniper man emesis but I just love the
way that little energy shot felt out of
that sniper F so you wasn't a
thousand-yard stare guy huh as Irene
forever because that was one of the
first night perks I got and I pretty
much taught myself with that one it had
one of the lowest aim-assist so I mean
that's just what I learned to live with
so nice yeah that was for my Bane see
that was that gunsmith uh-huh yeah I
love that gun that was one of my
favorite I used that for so many
nightfall videos because people ask me
all the time for my videos it was like
man what sniper is that Nigella Mel it's
just my Irene it's at the gunsmith and
it came up a couple times and I think
later on I eventually ended up getting
like a second one that had something
almost better than my first one and I
was an animal in a way I'm actually
trying to pull up my damn right now
thinking I've always wanted to go back
and looking for trophies so I had triple
tap I had injection mold so who induced
range on a sniper I don't care but in
faster stability faster handling and
increased stability and a mulligan so if
I miss a shot yeah it's like it was my
PvE greatness I could just use it and so
I get that triple tap like almost every
time I'm something I was never without
it yeah it was it was a favorite of mine
for sure down salute the Irene's out
there so we got our next giant topic
crucible whoa rankings here we go and
shout out in tastin nice little video
saw his
crucible rankings I think will benefit a
lot it'll give you a reason to go into
competitive because hopefully the main
idea here is if they match you up with
people at your
looks crucible it may take you a little
longer but you'll hopefully be really
playing with the people you should be
yes absolutely and yeah man this is cool
I mean for the most part you know we all
know that a competitive hasn't been
getting a lot of love you know a lot of
people don't play it I mean and now that
they're making these changes you know
we'll see I mean I will get into it I
have some suggestions as well as we as
you dive into the description but let's
get into what's changing so we've got
crucible ranks coming you guys may have
heard about them before both valor and
glory
so crucible ranks first are going to be
basically something to wear showing how
much you progressed either in crucible
in general or for glory that's going to
be the one or it's your true ranking if
you win it goes up if you lose it goes
down and there's different levels so
this is mostly I think the levels are
gonna be mainly for glory I know the
number value for valor is gonna go up
and that was gonna be interesting
because that one you can actually
literally like Call of Duty you can
prestige it you can start it back over
at zero that one's interesting I don't
know what that's gonna do what rewards
you're gonna get if it's anything major
more like ornaments or something or if
it's its own set that might be kind of
cool but I mean that's just as much as
if you play it on a crucible and you
know you prestige it like 10 times then
hey you live in crucible congrats you
might get some cool looking stuff
absolutely it's showing like a badge of
honor as well like so it's pretty cool
and it's nice just to reward the people
because before it was like okay I've
lived in crucible unless you go look him
up on wags let's go look him up on on
the Internet to be like hey how much
have you played ok you have you live in
there apparently that you have your own
personal cot in the corner all right
sweet oh yeah valor is kind of cool but
glory is the one I think that oh by far
glory as you guys can see on screen
there are crucible ranks and they are
Guardian brave heroic fabled mythic and
Legends kind of like those titles the
priests alidade the law become lazy you
know so with regards to those rankings
the big thing is
as you progress through the ranks you
get something the fact that you get
anything thank goodness yes are you
shaving to warn you they're doing work
I'll mute myself because I know you're
good I just
it sounded like shaving cuz cuz it was
almost like perfect noise for the
morning you're good I give my guardian
true money they were working on this man
sorry about that guys things happen to
his life job but with the crucible ranks
as you progress higher and higher it's
gonna be harder and harder to get there
so once you get up to a certain point
especially I think the fabled mythic and
legend you will have to actually
continue playing to keep that rank so
you're gonna slowly start to degrade if
you don't play so there's gonna be win
streak bonuses for both glory and valor
so if you get win streaks you get your
points a little bit faster in sequence
and then for glory the ranked one and
the competitive matches if you lose
consistently there's gonna be a lose
streak like deduction which that's gonna
hurt that's gonna be painful yeah man I
mean that that that's cool though I love
it because at the end of the day this is
Bungie right this is halo 2 this is the
ranking system right so it was always
you know you had to maintain that status
and I know we're gonna get into decay
and all that stuff later but to me that
is really cool
based on skill you've got to maintain it
you can drop you can go up
I'm loving this read this this is gonna
add so much life to the crucible for a
dedicated PvP guy I'm loving what this
is knowing continually but yeah so I
mean as you level up you'll get things
like crucible tokens personal engrams
master work cores just depending on how
far in level and that may be a reason if
you're going through valor and you're
like a competitive may not be my thing
there's a certain thing I want to go for
we'll get to that here in a little bit
which is really really cool but if
you've just going through valor and you
level up again it's like why would I
press these I never okay there's
actually a reason to keep getting
rewards
go through the ranks again so I like the
fact that they're definitely taking care
of it yeah absolutely
so yeah they cover valor is just a
progression just showing basically how
much time you've put into crucible so if
you get like you know a full 5 win
streak cool you're gonna get even more
points but it's never gonna go down
glory will go up and down with kills win
streaks lost rates all of those will
affect it basically get good and let's
go honestly that's one of those things
and again some of them some people may
crucify us for saying this but I think
we're probably on the same page not
everyone should be able to get
everything in the game right and it
works for any that works for life in
general that that's what it's got to be
and and I are you referencing said
reward that got everyone up in a tizzy
so it made that reg exclaim over there
with that desperado perk that gun looks
sick and I gotta keep it real I'm a PvE
player I don't know if I'm gonna get
better glory ranking you know but at the
end of the day it's one of those things
that you strive for one of those things
that you play the game that it's like
okay you know what you know I'm trying
very very hard to get this thing I'm
gonna try it like same thing with trials
I'm gonna try if I do I do but if I
don't I see someone with it it's like
you know what man you know what that guy
is he's a beast he earned it you know so
you got that that's what it's about at
the end of the day you've got a reward
that skill gap and give people something
to chase for good absolutely and yeah so
this rhetorics claymore it's a pulse
rifle the unique perk is desperado so
it's got outlaw which would you reload
what is outlaw it's like when you get a
kill it's faster reload right so now
with desperado when you use outlaw and
reload it's fire rate increases now it's
a slower fire rate pulse rifle now
normally when fire rate increases
whenever that happens damage falls on
account of it usually because they feel
like they have to balance it out this
time nope
so you're gonna have a high hitting
pulse rifle that now fires faster and
it's gonna hurt and if I'm on the other
end of that I'm gonna feel like yep
there it is again
that's scary and to know how useful
that's gonna be a PvE that's another one
yeah you get a quick kill on a Thrall
reload need go start pumping damage into
something hit like yeah you can get some
good like bounce back and forth between
a couple low-level enemies depending on
how long desperado lasts I probably
should look in all the YouTube videos
that are out there and actually probably
pay attention but however long it lasts
yeah it's gonna be doing some quick work
with whatever you're facing absolutely
but I just flat I like the idea they're
making something and this is season 3
only mmm for one it's limited forces
limited time only man getting while his
hat till probably September I mean I'm
guessing that's what season 3 qualifies
as but that's it now basically the way
they describe the ranks scroll back up
so you can see them Guardian brave
heroic this drops at fabled yes so the
way it's broken up they say are casual
and have potato aim and I'm not saying
anybody does or doesn't you crack it up
but potato I feel like that's just one
of those phrases I've heard and that's
stuck with me
I believe me I'm one of those at some
points I'm like wow I can't hit the
broad side of a barn but it's like but
if you're still in there having fun
working on valor working your way up
slowly and ranking you're working on
your skill and if you don't get there
you know what that's ok still work on
you everything takes practice and
literally practice you will get better
if you put in the time and start working
your way up that is something you can
work on achieving it's not impossible
but again it's not meant for everybody
and the people who are good deserve to
be rewarded and then they take that to
the next level I don't know what mythic
is gonna do I'm hoping something they
haven't exactly talked about that yet
but legend status is going to probably
be your 1% elites that's what I mean
it's gonna be a leap and the ornament
for the rhetorics Claymore only comes
from legend status so that's gonna be
rough to get
yeah that's not gonna be easy and and at
the end of the day like I love it it's
give these guys whoever that puts that
work in that dedication to get to that
level of skill should we reward it with
something that it's very potent and I'm
dying to see also what the ornaments
gonna look for for residence when you
get higher and what the other secret you
know rewards are like this is a great
direction I'm absolutely loving this
this reminds me of trials this reminds
me of getting those adept weapons
remember that they had snapshot this is
what destiny needs it's that chase and
another part of destiny which was huge
is again it's like I remember going into
the tower for the first time and seeing
a guardian in full trials gear and oh
and it had the full ornaments and it was
trials those like and trials I have
never been a trials King by any means so
I just see that and be like that's
awesome and I'm probably not gonna get
it but and for the guy that worked hard
it was a badge of honor
right absolutely no like he had though
trial ornaments he had whatever yet you
knew the act
those guys were beasts so it's like look
I gave my little bow as I approached
them in the tower and I can move but I
mean it's a sign of respect it's skill
to get there you have to earn it and
that's one of those reasons why I've
kind of enjoyed the more difficult games
is because when you get to fabled you're
gonna get that sense of like
accomplishment it's not just like here's
a random public event take this exotic
yeah like absolutely zero emotion
monotone I don't care
and that's the thing a lot of people got
to in this game and I think that's what
they're working on is people want to
care again about the stuff they get
we've got exotics thrown at us you can
me how you can be max level without
doing the endgame stuff and the story
you could literally skip half the
enemies and not die I mean it is not
it's not a difficult game it's really
not never has been
so
I don't know I'm just glad to see all of
this and I'm glad to see I just what I'm
waiting for and I think Gatto said it
too I just want the PvE equivalent yes
absolutely
to give the Peavy eyes it's only right
in fairness to give them absolutely so I
mean right now you've got random
cosmetics from strikes and you have
three guns hopefully that will be
changing I'd love to see something like
hey it's like if you're you know in the
top 100 and nightfall scores or maybe I
don't even know how many but that sounds
like there'd be a lot but it'd be like a
nightfall score or you've got say
there's a raid prestige boss you've got
a kill and you get a chance I mean
there's some of that stuff but as like
as long as they start bouncing that out
with PvE and come the fall then we're
bouncing on both sides and this is
starting to look really good
absolutely so they say for moving up in
ranks covered all that you've got rner
or armor ornaments emblems you've got
I'm so tired of emblems fancy if they
had like animated neon light up sign
emblems
but new weapons require players to earn
both valor and glory so even if you're
like good you still might have to put
some more time in players receive glory
packages only the first time a new rank
is reached in each season so if you lose
a match and drop a rink you won't
receive another match there's no point
in bouncing up and down which is good
they you know people aren't gonna milk
it that way but yeah Red Rocks flame war
sounds pretty awesome desperado and
outlawed I don't even know it's just
gonna be nuts and then if you kill
somebody with it with desperado I'm
literally thinking it they just said it
right here running and definitely get a
headshot kill reload it again Desperados
back and keep going that's like oh god
it's gonna be deadly man in the right
hands a skills handling right now -
they're in a good spot so that one
because like auto rifles are just steady
hand cannons people use them forever but
incentive to use a pulse I'm kind of
digging that because it's what I would
say between d1 and d2 that has been
they've
had their moments but I don't think
they've been usually ultra hide there
was a moment for red death where it was
pretty good but pulse rifles haven't I
don't think seeing the overall love and
kind of glad to see them getting a
little bit here it's nice absolutely so
for your rankings you can earn your
valor within quick play Rumble and
mayhem so kind of your weekly playlists
in would play but they're leaving out
iron banner and trials because those are
gonna be your own things they've got
assets they got all their own things in
them their own rankings all those things
are there so separating those which is
fine they got their own vendors anyway
shacks will take care of this stuff I
think and then glory only comes from
competitive so you're gonna have to jump
in that competitive play list you're
gonna have to basically get in there for
the countdowns and get in there for
those other types of modes that not
everybody does but hopefully if more
people jump in the player base will get
a little little boosts you're not
playing against ridiculous people all
the time mm-hmm and matchmaking may take
a little longer I'm fine with it I'm
finally a man yeah I was like now if
they could ever do background
matchmaking like if I could go run
around etz like go to crucible and kind
of queue it up and have a little thing
in the corner that says hey you'll be
loading in here in five seconds do you
want to go sure
or of him in something that would be a
great thing for them to add and I heard
somebody say that probably dado as well
yeah but yeah so background matchmaking
while you're doing other things that
would be amazing cuz you just have to
sit there and wait yeah you could do
that if you did that for like guided
games that would help
I mean I'm guided games needs a lot of
help but that background matchmaking
would help a lot so be like am at least
just gonna run around and shoot stuff or
I'm gonna wander around the tower and
look at things not just I'm gonna sit
here and stare at my screen for 20
minutes and wait other things that a
bleed oh there we go so here we go why
should you keep earning glory every week
so this is where we start talking about
the player decay do you want to jump in
pretty much basically sandy sweet glory
rank or change depend on number games
played
hang out at three games per week players
rank fabled and below will earn bonus
glory rank points each week for players
ranked mythic and legend each match
completely reduced the amount of glory
rank decayed
up to preventing the decay for the week
this means if you're a player in the
mythical legend you need to hop in the
competitive playlist at least three
times a week to maintain your status
then it goes on into a wool matchmaking
be based on glory ranks in the
competitive Oilers competitive playlist
will be or shaving again I apologize at
the start of season three we're gonna
reset the skill bucket and blah blah
blah I'm gonna let you take them could
they get on my nerves you know I'm
saying you're gonna have to play to say
that you can maintain your ranking
that's number one and then as far as
this our matchmaking as far as the glory
and stuff like that you means whether
you win or lose your skill and rank will
go up and down according so this is kind
of getting that halo 2 system that we
were talking about and as always we've
never done they're gonna be reiterating
and proving the systems so that you have
time to sink your teeth into the ranks
they'd love to hear your feedback so I
like the fact that it's still not
definitive they're gonna evolve it based
on the feedback we give them but I like
the fact that it requires activity you
have to continually play to maintain
that rank you just can't like get there
and sit throne and have people come at
you and be like now I'm not playing I'm
good exactly you're gonna have to
continually maintain and earn that rank
and I like that this is really cool it's
a hardcore separator I think it's dope
I'm all about it man yeah there's only
one line it says each week your glory
will change depending on the number of
games you played and it says maxing out
at three games a week I'm not sure
that's right hmm why would three games a
week be all that you like if you to
determine your glory like if you played
twenty matches in a week you lost your
first three but then you won your next
17 that wouldn't kind of suck so I don't
let I don't know if that's like a typo
or something I'm kind of hoping it is it
seems a little off but the idea of like
decay you got to play three matches a
week and if you know you're having an
off week you might get dropped down a
little bit but you know if you have
three solid games then maybe I think
maybe minimum of three games a week
might be the idea of that
there but who knows there's a good pun
but I like the idea it's like you can't
just sit at the top and milk it you
gotta kind of stick with it it's
incentive to come back and even just
play on Tuesday for a little bit get
your three matches and it's still some
reason to login and that's that's the
hobby thing they're going back to give
us a reason let's be aware this is this
helps promote engagement for destiny
this is what which is what's been
lacking right that that reason after
after they've reset you know you need
another reason to keep coming and this
is this is one of those things and I
love it
yep so yeah I'm digging that one
matchmaking based on Gloria rinks and
the competitive playlist it will be
using our existing matchmaking system at
the start of season three we're gonna
reset the skill bucket and competitive
to give every player an equal start as
they begin to climb so that's a good
thing at least it'll be fresh so I'm
sucking it up and I'm in the bottom tier
well this will be there with the rest of
guys I'm gonna be jumping up at a mythic
or legend straightaway that's for sure
it was a different man those guys are
sweat baby their sweat no sweat and I
got a whole lot so much salt in my hands
I can't see but yeah as you guys win or
lose hopefully will be based on your
recent skill so whether you started low
and you're worried about jumping in at
kind of a lower level get a fresh start
you know go in there and the Kadett the
idea like if you feel like you don't
want to skew yourself too far don't try
and go into competitive your first time
you're going in for your skill sets with
like your two most skilled friends in
the world
pick your average friends go in there
figure out where you should be and
you're loving it and enjoy it more
good point good point because it will be
skill base it'll be Hilo base yep that's
a very good point
and I did making some changes that
changed but they also caused a lot of
concern I'm rumbling I've been hearing
on the interwebs in reference to this
you know obviously there's gonna be some
crying oh I have to get you know I can't
get the Redux participation that'll stop
that exactly get good the second thing
I've been hearing is well what about
solo play like
you know if I'm a solo play and I'm
playing with blueberries you know what a
chance is you know and apparently I
believe one of the PvP designers jumped
in front of it actually I'm already one
step ahead so you alright alright no
we'll get there we'll get there but
believe me that's a huge piece so little
death we'll get down to it absolutely
but for those who want to say too long
didn't read or too long gimme bullets
Valor caps of 20,000 points features a
win streak bonus no loose treat bonus
it'll be reset when you complete so you
can keep going through it as many times
as you can
at ornaments emblems weapons you might
have emblem varieties maybe there's if
you do it ten times you get really cool
look at emblem and if it looks kind of
awesome on the end I might be playing a
little more again incentive to stay in
it exam requires a fixed number of
Valerie sets to earn some rewards you
might have to do it like four or five
times to gets a weapon or number ten for
the awesome
so the idea there's gonna be incentive
to keep doing it right and what I like
is that valor is getting their own day
on ornaments emblems and rewards as well
so just for the time dedication that is
being rewarded because obviously you
know the people with glory they're gonna
be getting some hotness you know no
doubt but at least a valor guys are
getting something right just for that
skully I mean if you like if you love
mayhem and you love rumble and quick
play and just playing those and getting
in the mix it's like you're still gonna
get some shows out if you're gonna get
some some unique stuff from it and for
the guys who live in glory they're gonna
have a different set of stuff so I mean
they're going to they're not gonna get
Valor from those competitive matches
they're gonna have to go into both so
sometimes you'll be playing against the
sweaty sometimes you like the glory will
be kind of having its own feel so yeah
it'll actually kind of split some of the
competitive people while they're
grinding out as well so absolutely so
glory on the other hand as we said it
caps out at fifty five hundred points
which I have no idea how they're gonna
work so it sounds like a big number
though mm-hmm features win streak
bonuses and lost streak penalties for
recurring losses you can earn bonus rank
points or fend off decay by completing
at least three competitive matches each
week so at least three that seems to
make sense
yeah resets each season but just once I
mean it's just gonna be your ongoing
thing during the season
same thing ornaments emblems and weapon
rewards we know the exclusive weapon at
level fable which is in 40 difficulty
and then the ornament is at legend level
so that one's they're really cool and
mm-hmm
so they said how are you gonna make sure
everyone plays fair in the ranked
environment update to 1.2 will have more
security systems things like that
hopefully less you know DDoS things we
know competitive get sweaty people find
any way they can but Bungie tries to be
as secure as possible and that's one
thing I will say is like if you ever
want to have a secure can go play pout
go on PC I mean battle that's as secure
as you can probably hope for between
most things they got a pretty lockdown
so that'll help a little bit if you're
looking for a different platform but
they're trying to do everything they can
and it's always a work in progress even
when the people went out to the
community summit they're like yeah we're
doing security we're not going to talk
about it moving on like making changes
so here's where you were talking about
any opponents so they're working on some
under the hood changes for solo players
there's other games where you pair up
with say it's three solo players in a
team of three on a six-man game well the
other side's gonna hopefully get matched
up with the same thing now it may take
you a little while to get matched but
you're gonna have a more even pairing
three people that might be running as a
team and you look okay those three look
coordinated the other three are off to
and who knows what but at least you're
in the same boat mm-hm so if you're
going against a team of four or six or
two and two and two and two like you're
gonna be similarly paired up hopefully
so they're gonna try at least to improve
it it always seems to be a work in
progress it's a moving target all the
time right but they said basically
player just and fire teams have
substantial advantages if you don't
think they do you're crazy
no way for random people and I see four
people on another clan yes the fact that
you can communicate verbally especially
if you're playing together it's like
Lee's in it and you can say hey they're
coming back I see somebody coming here
meet me on this point just that verbal
communication as opposed to even just
waiting for the radar or control points
to do their thing you're so far behind
all the time hmm
so what they're working on doing is
instead of using
normal skill value in a fireteam so
you're on normal you know control match
will quit play there's four people
they're gonna use a modified value that
takes your fireteam size into account so
if the Lark if you are in a larger
fireteam the larger the potential
modification so we don't want to try and
completely nullify the benefit of
playing into mark oh it's kind of a
balance but and they said their initial
values are conservative but hopefully it
kind of leads you so what is it like if
your skill level of the team of the
people you're with if you are skill
levels reasonable you're gonna probably
have a higher skill matching even if
you're playing against some randoms that
are right better than you you're running
as a team so your skills gonna kind of
be matched if your solos at a low at a
lower level you're probably gonna be
even farther down the totem pole of
matchmaking so it's a little more
separation between teams and solos and
if you are solo but you're a higher
skill then you might start facing those
like medium teams it's kind of a way to
balance that out I can tell I like it I
like it I'll be kind of curious to see
how much it's in effect how much it
feels like it's in play and then again
these are the changes you can read about
them but you never know until you get
your hands on
I don't know what do you think on this
one I know you were you were just been
in there someone let you get your think
this is really cool I I'm just listen we
have to see how all this stuff is
implemented right before we can make
final calls on it but at the end of the
day the fact that they're even thinking
about the solo player is a huge thing
because prior to that let's be real like
bungees pvp didn't really care for I
didn't care but they never had any
algorithms in account for the
single-player so I think that is huge
especially let's be honest it's gonna
get sweaty everybody's gonna be in that
damn glory playlist everybody's goin
what that redux you know it's you know
and guys got trying to get it poppin and
you know it's gonna at least they have
something in place to try to help those
guys out I think that's very cool you
guys know I was like I like to see it
just the acknowledgment alone is the
fact that they're finally seeing it's an
issue and there's enough other games out
there I mean you
got your buddies over a blizzard they do
overwatch and that's where I like you
play overwatch and you literally see
who's in a team who's not you get in
destiny yes see like okay so there's a
little black bar and it was a chunk of
like those four together in this and if
you saw like you're on the team of six
and the other six are together you're
like ah crap it was like they noticed it
then but they never did anything about
it so I'm glad actually trying to make
it better so you have a better
experience exactly any knowledge in it
that's he should do I mean if you're a
crafty or you're an M test you're one of
those these mode guys and you know in
your skill level is gonna be up there so
if you go and random solo you're paired
with a team you're still gonna have that
skill that bounces it out some if you
nor your average Joe from wherever and
you're like him somewhere in the middle
and I'm playing solo you're gonna
probably be bumped down per se you
probably wanted to be bumped out but
those guys are gonna be a bumped up
hopefully a little farther from you
though odds are you just less chances to
go face us all a team exactly exactly
like that's I mean that's it makes sense
it just does you're playing against the
team and you're by yourself it's just a
rough date and you can usually tell the
solos versus the teams you run around a
corner you're like aw crap there's three
people I'm dead like it it's so obvious
when they're running well especially
when you start trying to go two points
and then every time you see like you see
your radar you like I don't know how
many it is and three come around the
corner boom boom done and it's like you
can't win no it's not like you see dots
on your radar you see a color and you
just see what comes around the corner
Shaq say I've had enough I'm going to
yeah I wish there was a point where I
honestly what I wish there was a point
where if I was in a matches like can I
opt in for mercy can you do this faster
and there's moments here like this is
just give them the W that got this I'm
gonna go ahead and put one in the Lost
Colony
absolutely so well as they said iron
banner was running straight back into it
so next week we've got iron from the
last time so nice Oh 6v6 baby it was fan
6v6 iron banner give me your thoughts
man love it
love it and to be honest it's at the
point now you want it's it feels so good
it feels so like the one that I'm like
six feet across the bog ask like I don't
like part of me now it's like I love it
so much and yes it makes Iron Man and
special but it's like I need to have a
six week six month when iron banner is
not around like I need this well we
still don't have a rift I want that
that's like I think that would be
another good like objective mode yeah
but I think six players would be the
right way to do it I think four would be
too small for rift I think you do you
have to do a minimum of six mm-hmm rift
so maybe that's the way they kind of
work that one back and we're not gonna
get a game-mode for this one but maybe
in the fall we get a new crucible mode
we'll see there's some new mode man oh
no it's just for the Fall whoa okay so
for this is just a little tidbit aside
here from the Destiny community summit
most people so far have only been able
to say how they're how they felt about
the event they could say hey we ask this
question hey we ask this question they
gave answers but they can't say what but
the big leg kind of news piece is
there's a new mode and it's not what's
coming out with a war line that's
separate that's kind of like a public
event thing we'll get there in a little
bit but there's a new mode dip it
different from anything else in destiny
that's ever been in destiny yeah and I
was like what what and everybody was
just like just strapped to the chair no
one wanted to stop playing that I know I
can't get my head wrapped around what I
see I can't get my head wrapped around
what it could possibly be because you
want a shooter late yeah the only thing
I can think of is maybe I know back in
the day you know we used to do our okay
back it always talked about maybe like a
PvE and PvP mode Nick's kind of like
what halo does like a warzone see that
is what I've been waiting on for a while
I was right that so I'm thinking these
are my guess is its some type of PvP PvE
combo warzone kind of a deal or don't
laugh not funny if this is it but the
second biggest is never know by all
means the second what I mean no one's no
one's gonna admit that until it's
actually officially announced now at the
helm yeah we know that college is
there's a strong to the strong rumor
they're successful for at night quietly
popular everywhere I saw a podcast and
they're like we have twitch here it was
at a strip club and they're like what do
you think is happening are they just
like watching fortnight streams like
while like like a sports TV thing or do
they have the ladies play it's like I
don't know either way it's crazy
no what does they get slightly popular
so I mean the Battle Royale is pretty
much what everybody thinks
III is gonna be battle royale mode like
that's what people are like gonna get
tired of hearing I'm sure but no I think
war zone would be probably the best
thing because the game has both PvE and
PvP to it so if you had something to
wear there's a giant ogre City I mean it
it kind of has the feel of I don't if
you've ever watched or seen dota at all
you've seen it okay yeah I mean you've
got a little bit of elements in there
because you have some PvE elements on
the map some kind of major bosses that
give you a big swing and other points or
give you a big power boost at a time
when you kill it but again it's still
the open field to where you've got to
you know you can get ransacked while
you're doing it you so you still have to
defend yourself while working on PvE
targets and I think combining both of
those is what this game has been lacking
so I mean that's where's like when it
comes to faction wars if you can have
open world PvP that's the type of stuff
that would start making
interesting so if you have a mode like
that a giant map please I would that
would be probably my job that would be
my wish that every al oh my god the
number of supers that would be flowing
what do you think so you got 58 void
warlock source 50 first 50 of hammer
Titans and you just throw your supers at
the same time it just break the game
with words I don't even know how they
would implement that in the game when
destiny you know I was like it would be
insane I don't know if they could do it
but I don't know if the engine kind of
things I think that might be the biggest
thing is involved because babbles on the
on the front end I know there's a lot
going on in program I'm not saying it's
easy to do but it doesn't have the
complicated
flight systems that doesn't he does
going on it just doesn't it's got fairly
simple weapons and things so that regard
they're not calculating quite as much
with range perks and modifiers and
they're everything's fairly set so mm-hm
yeah for me warzone would be kind of
amazing that's that's my wish that's my
dream so and if it ever made it in there
who I would probably and that the one
because I think mark on Guardian radio I
listen to him and he basically said when
this comes that this is my mode of
choice I'm like no that's what like what
what's cool about what we've heard about
it so far
everybody has universally said this mode
is amazing like every single birthday
it was the consensus mode that everyone
talked about it crazy and this is coming
from the same group of people and this
is the idea as well this is why I think
the community summit was a great thing
from what I've heard from multiple
sources there is some idea they brought
out so the group and saying hey we're
thinking about this and basically
unanimously they said that's not gonna
be that's not gonna be what you want and
that was kind of one of their like
bigger so they literally they went back
he was on the first of the few days came
back the second day and the real like
well what about this
they're like that's better in the right
direction like some major thing that was
gonna be coming out most of the
community like fairly well
representative me not everybody's there
but it's a good cross-section of people
basically said yep trash that before it
came out and saved us at like six months
to a year being like really those are
the type of things why I think that's
gonna serve them well and hopefully they
do it again today our names in that
second hat please
exact please get up in the building
please um dude I can't even under state
like what you just said because the old
regime let's just say would have never
done anything like that
and the fact part of me is like
curiously of what was presented I know
it's gonna come out eventually
you mean blazes like it was like what
was presented that was actually shot
down but the fact that they humbled
themselves the next day and said okay we
took your feedback you don't like this
this is what we have instead and then
everybody says yes this is what we're
talking about so to me these are all
positive signs and I've got I'm I'm
really optimized I know we've been doom
and gloom for months we've been just
seeing this thing like an it come around
kind of come around and for the most
probably worried we just like I don't
know you know it for the first time II
like I got that glimmer glimmer in my
eye yeah I'd be able to see it a body I
don't want to get too ahead of myself
because shout out to Daddo you know and
I believe talking about this 5,000 watts
you know they still have to deliver
right you can take all this feedback but
if you don't implement it you don't act
on it yes doesn't do anything but the
fact that they're being so transparent
the fact that people are impressed
really impressed what they see with
September gives me a lot of hope and I
got I got it for the positive maybe just
maybe destiny could come back I was like
it's good it's got a shot and I think
it's it's again we've been saying
building blocks for a while these are
starting to be some substantial building
blocks we're looking at so kind of like
what we're hearing
[Music]
we've got some stuff about errors and
things in the weekly update and they've
got some videos ran out metals some good
stuff in there so apparently some dude
was working hard on the nightfall tops
course arms deal you got Johnny Hopkins
in number one and number two you got two
sets of people together trying to max it
out if you guys want some twitter
backgrounds by the way thank you Bungie
crushing it they just provided them for
you free banners go nuts so spend your
time enjoy what you got well we had just
a little more to talk about when it
comes to just the reveal stream so I
know we covered the Bungie and so they
covered three main things first
basically just a little bit with the
story of the expansion so we've got an
ax break
so she is real which the rumors on that
piece were true with cybernetic axe
those are awesome by the way
very cool I want to watch that video in
4k and teach texturing shot of a rise
and just be like I don't you could use
that as a picture wall it's crazy but
yeah rise are awesome currently they
work like machines so but you see her
she's gonna be your main vendor your
basically your NPC on Mars mm-hmm and it
is Mars now it's the northern part of
Mars so you can see the ice caps are
there but there's still some desert up
there but it's gonna be cold you know we
see hive they're covered in ice
basically totally snow yeah chilly
chilly hive chilly bones there have a
little Okita that's the enemy type and
yeah it was like those are still alive I
don't think they quite get new enemy
types oh yeah I mean did they say it or
am I crazy why did I think that was
don't I think what maybe some of the
leaks were the fake leaks said that yeah
thankfully yeah that's what we've may
have assumed but everybody was shocked
that it was high right I don't know I
don't even know what I expected it to be
but I guess hive is an option yep
so we had our reveal about her so I mean
she's gonna be your vendor her
background is pretty cool you
can watch the video stream it's fine
watch the trailer it's pretty cool so
that's their then we had all to talk
about crucible and the exotic changes we
got to see sky burners oath in action
hard light and we've seen those before
so that's the other one the final piece
that we got to see which the Destiny
communites um I got to see is the hive
escalation percolation yes so first off
you pretty much have to complete the
campaign to even be able to activate
this thing no it's not just a random
public event you're gonna see on Mars
mm-hmm and secondly it's towards the end
game level mm-hmm now the stream they
showed basically they were high level
characters they wanted at least show you
guys the activity not be dying all the
time oh and the twitch people went out
they were you know mid low level
characters and they said it was rough it
was a struggle so I don't know from what
you've seen about it what do you think I
get the classic horde mode arm I like
that the bosses rotate so that kind of
gave me like it wasn't a court of Oryx
kind of feel um I like that it's a six
play activity right I believe is six
well it's three but it's public so you
can have more people okay so it's that
whole deal again and what else stupid
okay is at the end of the day it's like
can we get some type of six player
patrol activity yeah you know like come
on now but I mean it seems cool I just
like that they my main appeal to it was
the grind for the weapons and that each
still it was almost like strike specific
Luke her boss and different things
and I'm a little biased with this
because I'm such a fan of the sleeper
stimulant I like that that's my baby
like people love Gale asleep it was my
thing I live and die by that gun that it
really came out of my life heavy slot
you know back in the day and so just to
see the theme of all of these weapons in
that vein it's cool and giving me hope
that maybe there's like some type of a
secret quest an exotic quest you know
I'm saying for sleep or so I'm just
prankster
one of my favorite exotics water and um
yeah man so I mean I like the the weapon
grind aspect of it you know I like that
it's difficult you know and if they
adding like a weekly thing so we'll see
I mean I don't want to retract it just
yet but it to me it seems like a better
version of Court of Oryx a little horde
mode of what was that one art was it the
forge yeah oh my god so it's kinda like
Forge and Oryx mixed a little bit but I
like the weapon I liked it they've added
almost strike specific loop so to speak
yeah I mean it's more stuff to grind for
I hope they have some of their own perks
to it as well yes some of them have seen
they might have a little bit to it but
if I'm gonna go for something I don't
want just another auto rifle in this 330
or whatever category like mmm
some of the stuff distinct and they've
really got that I know they're working
on fall with weapon randomization slots
and all that stuff but to make this
stuff right now matter you got to give
us a reason to go for these different
bosses to kill go for the grind like is
it this big again okay I need to fight
this boss it's like it's actually in
there but I need to be a reason for me
to log in not just exactly what I'm here
anyhow I miss files and once he has a
great video up is that a lot of these
weapons that we are very cool like CT
talk about the shotgun mmm like a little
sleeper sleeper similar shotgun it was
also like a sub sub machine and had like
a perk I think maybe someone had a video
out or where pretty much like it if you
burst the shield of somebody with the
sub then you get double percent
precision damage with your kinetic if
you switch over yeah I saw that
so I'm seeing cool unique perks powerful
weapons people are people are saying
that these weapons wore mine kind of
exclusive weapons through escalation
mode are very good so that I like
because again if you do an endgame
content you want to be rewarded with
good stuff and that was the problem with
the Leviathan stuff and you know earlier
with it with the prestige raid well you
never saying like there wasn't that that
grind you know that that carrot that
made
say okay I want to do this activity
because I want this weapon you know that
kind of a deal so I'm hopeful I'm not
gonna get over the top with it
you know but it I mean for the grind I'm
doing it I'm telling that right back I
will be doing it so I mean it'll give
you some and even if it's like one more
thing just to do for the week it is one
more thing to do for at least five weeks
there's five bosses so that'll be cool
we actually get a relic back looks like
Who am I trying to think who's the New
Orleans kept Marvel guy gambit yeah like
a gambit staff and not purple butted
solar energy throw it and explore this
like it looks pretty cool mm-hmm just
fun to see a relic back there is funny I
destroy let's not forget our hive swords
coming back high up swords coming back -
yep almost forgot about that one I mean
we got some good stuff so I mean I'm
kind of digging everything so far mm-hm
with cautious optimism yeah absolutely
like I said courses happen to me based
like I said no disrespect to the stream
they said when destiny comes out with
new content you know the marketing
team's gonna knock it out the park you
know we've been burned by Osiris we know
that I get it but to me we got a plan we
got sparrows exactly got sparrows it
means Titan it's good not a big circle
like or like Osiris like a mercury you
know I mean but to be honest to me it's
all about these new systems that they've
added it's all about master works for me
it's all about crucible ranking it's all
I'm so happy with getting new DLC new
story missions no strikes yeah yeah and
raelia great but to me the systems are
really what's exciting me the most I'm
gonna do the story I'm gonna do all that
stuff but I can't wait to start my chase
for like you know what's the you know
exact mass to work for you know whatever
sweet business or whatever gun it is you
know and just keep that grind going that
excites me that's the stuff that I look
forward to logging into destiny to
everyday that mystery that intrigue when
the community comes together and tries
to figure out okay how do we get this
you know remember the days of the
sleeper simulant no orbital prime was
ridiculous
yeah man remember all but overall man it
is so many things like that and I just
remember fond memories that can really
just sit there okay
how do you do it you know what do you do
okay this day you can only get the black
spindle on you know what I mean like it
was just so many cool moments and these
are the things that may destiny destiny
to me even little things like the crutch
of crota dropping right which let had
its own crest line that go going to the
whole other stuff for the necrochasm and
things like that
the mystery of deaths and that that's
what that's these built on you know and
have that kind of stuff back even in a
smaller form with exotic mass works is
very exciting and the last thing i want
to say is that being it i didn't think
they would go the extra mile at Sawgrass
works the way they are now I'm even more
confident for exotic masterwork armor to
see what they deal with that they've
that's that's the summertime question
mark yes looking good
Bowden bounties exotic masterworks but
man for me it's the the armor the
weapons seem like they will be game
changers to a point of hopefully the
hard decision but your play style
changes or what come from the armor yes
and that's the ones I want to see what
they do they've got to make him special
they've got a crank and there's so many
there's so many items that I have in my
fall and I'm like if they would just
bump up and buff the utility you know I
like those disease warlock boots on Luna
fication and I'm like you know in theory
it should act like a kind of like a
Titan barricade and stuff like that it
just the functionality is just not there
so they just this I'm very hopeful now
it because they're going so much the
extra mile with exotic weapons I'm
getting a little confident do it ready
they bite get the armor right you know
sit and really bump those bad boys
everything what if they do do the same
thing what if they add next to perk with
a catalyst do the okay
you know the big thing for me on the
armor while exotic masterworks can be
cool they need to rework the armor
system to me before that to ever matter
okay what do you want what do you want
define they got stats don't matter so
much so I mean that's the stuff I want
to see like I know they thought they
talked about mobility a little bit and
they're working on the technical pieces
you got resilience
you've got recovery as well but it's all
the things of like hey when I pick up a
piece of armor it's like in Mesa shun
said this to me is like a one of the
Warlock helm from Kings fall because it
had grenade reload speed and mm-hmm
those are the type of perks don't want
to see again I want to pick up armor and
have it change my character it's like
the mods are working on it and those I
know they're working on redoing but mods
that's why people like hey our mods just
gonna be like weapon randomization but I
was like don't forget about the armor
the armor needs some huge help and if
it's gonna be to mod slots in there so
you actually can start changing more of
the mods matter more mm-hmm
so are the pieces that I need armor the
exotic masterworks hopefully it'll make
like some of that good but I still have
four other slots that are kind of may
mm-hmm so I'll wear one and hopefully
that's a game changer but I want the
rest of my armor to be good too and
that's where I'm waiting for fall to see
what they do I'm curious about the
master works for armor and I hope they
take it to level they are with the
weapons this is this is a good step for
exotics quick question wins wins exotic
masterwork armors on it on the devilís
how can members awesome okay nope yeah
I'm looking at it right now it is
summertime some are seasonal and
affectionate faction rallies bounties PC
clan chat and exotic armor sandbox
mm-hmm that's your summertime and then
fall is gear collections records weapons
lot changes and weapon randomization so
that's the big stuff but yeah for me
it's just like go back to d1 cuz I mean
if you go back and pick just any piece
of armor and we're gonna go okay so
what's the helm for mm-hmm
like Titan helm from taking King
she's got increased super energy gain
from
in the darkness that was one you always
wanted on for PE replenish health each
time you pick up an orb and that's on
like the helm then you've got the
gauntlets that would have hand cannon
reload speed or grenade throw distance
then you had chess pieces that give you
more ammo like your heavy ammo or pulse
rifle ammo so you'd have like a chess
piece that would work well if you're run
on pulse rifles and there was so many
more pieces to grind for on that would
change like what I would go for what I
would equip I mean it reduces incoming
solar burn damage like if you want to
have a burn or increased armor when
using a solar Club subclass those are
all I don't know why they removed so
many of those exactly those are very
very cool very cool very good utility
and games you reason to want to wear
specific armor sets oh and also lets you
know we already talked about this as
well might you know the whole armor set
thing you know a full set you know that
kind of stuff we've talked about this
kind of stuff before so it's gonna be
interesting to see how they handle you
know exotic armor masterworks very
curious but I will say I mean fantastic
job so far from what I'm seeing but this
reworking of weapons so that's given me
a little confidence on yeah I mean I
like what I'm seeing I'm with you I like
what I'm seeing it takes a while to make
changes and that's what I'm saying it's
like so far these are all I don't see I
don't have anything to really like break
down about this right a new content
looks good the new mode that they can
fit into Mars
it looks cool it's got some to grind for
the weapons better these are all good
things
yeah sorry I'm using it to cough no no
it's coffee but yeah there's there's
still more I want and these are
hopefully all the questions at the
summit but they're working on but but do
you feel hopefully are you hopeful so
you look at God of War which is like a
very much an action game dude go back to
we're coming full circle
[Music]
it's uh very much it's an action game
but they don't vent to some of the RPG
stuff with gear I've got some stats um
like you're unlocking abilities as you
go pieces those are what make me spend
more time and again absolutely is that
what what I call the minutia all right
yes absolutely packs in and moving
around and leveling up and getting those
little statistical advantages and stuff
like that and you get with progression
and that's what we miss and and yeah I'm
with you man I want you and if they can
they can start adding these things we'll
see man I definitely I definitely
understand because it's optimism yeah so
good things I think the warm mind update
is gonna be is this the one that brings
people back no I want say it all the
time listen if you've been hating yen
coming back foot it for the destiny
hardcore this is this is this is
promising I'm singing baby steps in the
right direction you know we still notice
wait what's much more to be done you
know and from what we hear that
September taken King equivalent might be
that one what we hear between the new
mold all the changes and shout out so
I'm gonna give Milan game to shout out
real quick that he was he was invited
you got to chance to represent the law
community shelter by she should have
been out a while by Frank there but I'm
not gonna get into there we shut the
Milan because he really did a fantastic
job and actually standing ovations Amani
because but we just complained about
last week about raid layers and
disconnect he had one of the most
in-depth questions and he said from day
one when he first got to the summit
there wasn't a member of the law team
there he was concerned Barrett the next
day they had a lower person there him
mercury sat down and they got busy and
they asked all the questions that I
needed to hear about the Osiris being I
kind of character while Lord's not being
respected how raid layers how thinking
is in a perfect example of continuity
strikes build you up to Oryx
you finished that it was the finish the
raid concluded the story right yeah he
got so in depth again shouted the Milan
man he really broke that hole down as to
why tinking was the example and how a
raid layer completely disconnects you he
talked about arm just inconsistency talk
about when we talk about how like when
you got the fragments from the that was
affirmed that was learned about the book
of sorrows you know all these things
that kind of brought you in and
respected the lore and from what I read
again for September these changes are
supposed to be implemented these changes
and of course their unending so I can't
say it but he'll say things like when he
asked about certain things and people
say so what did you feel about their
answer towards you know this I was very
positively encouraged by this answer
like I was neutrally you know encouraged
right answer but for the most part the
majority of everything the answered was
positive responses so that's what I want
to include no absolutely and that's one
thing a lot of people that's I think
quite taken King had stuff that it was
it's the intangibles that you can't kind
of put your finger on but if you go
through you land on the dread-nots and
then your first strike isn't like you
got the shield brothers in there
figuring out why they crash-landed then
on the other side of the dread-nots
you've got the what's the dark strike I
can't remember the name of it right now
oh yeah yeah with the dude with the
helmet that you chopped off and you wear
as a hat oh oh mom was did the dark
blade dark blade yeah the dark blade
yeah I don't know if that's quite the
strike but yeah that's who would fight
remember airs getting all excited and
that's still within the same same ship
it's talking about auras who tried to
overtake him that piece is there it's
like you guys we're all tied within the
theme not here's Mars
here's a random vex Tricon necess for
PlayStation exclusives I will tell you
typically do not fit the lore they're
not you
too much of anything so they don't worry
about missing so much on that but yeah
if you have here's this thing on Mars
you better place that's new strike both
of them on Mars somewhere another one of
them in an underground like cavern or
catacombs or an icy open air like
whatever it needs to connect to your
content otherwise what's the point
absolutely same with the rate as well
and the raid layers attempt maybe but
yeah I mean I so yeah for what myelin
games saying all that stuff those are
those are the things when your whole
world is connected it just has a little
different feel and it's it makes a
difference mm-hmm absolutely
using it and the fact that he would call
them out on it they want to get answers
they had the story lead person there you
know and again according to them you
know these are things that are gonna be
implemented they're very hopeful you
know for what they hear about September
and including this new mode so you know
we'll see man it's you know some
positive light we'll see what happens
I need I was like and it's just that
stuff for us to look forward to so I'll
know pretty good might do it the way
Bungie does and wrap this thing up with
the warm minds trailer so the full two
minutes so do you want to crank up your
sound
I know you're kind of sharing on your
side I don't know why mine broke I'm
sorry about that they're going to be
living through your Twitter right I am
going to go ahead and play the trailer
and we will wrap up just shortly after
that so let's get this thing going
you're gonna have bad boy
she's that ninja yeah she she's got the
whole you got to give me the narrative
play-by-play very bad now she's hanging
on the wall with the knife oh did I late
climbing up stand out on top of the ice
oh yeah that gun she's on her back very
unique looks like an end of a quest item
and the giant shadow over the top yeah
oh yeah I know that's there's a lot of
history with that yeah so it's good
stuff guys honestly it's pretty sweet Oh
course fold on full screen
cut that one gone
well that's my background guys hopefully
you enjoyed looking at that yeah sorry
about Sam I guess I guess we'll work out
the kinks on my side I'll figure why
Google always betrays us midstream
hopefully you enjoyed I'm gonna go see
Avengers I shout out to all of you to do
the same
yes keep it free I'm not gonna say a
word I'm not saying words I'm gonna be
tight-lipped I'm gonna go live in God of
War after after my break as well yeah so
we got some stuff to look forward to I
mean and these are all setting up the
fall to be better and better so I'm
liking what I'm seeing and we got a week
and a half till this thing comes out
we're not that week and a half none of
you right around very grand will be real
yes
cannot wait all right well you guys know
where to find both of us so me Twitter
ebon tus twitch.tv slash ubuntu and
youtube as well if you guys want to drop
a like if you enjoy these videos comment
if you got questions you want to see in
a future video please and also just hit
that subscribe button for both of us at
the alert bell get those notifications
always help support the channel any way
you can so
you guys thank you very much and for you
Cognito of course at Lido here on
Twitter and you already know what I need
Oh on our Xbox and our cognitive 360 on
PlayStation iron law podcast will be
returning this Sunday in the realm of
the Lords on the inner circle YouTube
channel this week just garden will
actually be there these yeah they
rescheduled last week sir the
last-minute cancellation but uh just
going from windows sent recordings from
our window central will be in the
building it should be a fun fun show
please stop by show support and of
course please support our Guan says on
his twitch you know he's doing good
great content right now and as well as
the iron world podcast YouTube we got a
couple subscribers today because of
Flashpoint very appreciative and
especially to chat for the dude a lot of
the people new faces I've seen in there
talking destiny so that gets to show me
that you know works not for nothing
people do appreciate what we do and
everyone's actually getting excited
again so that's really good to see it
you're gonna ride this thing out man no
yeah so thank you guys for everything as
always enjoy your weekend and we'll be
back next week see and if there's
anything major that drops it's probably
just the calm before or mindstorm you
enjoy that infinity war enough and a
nose man yep when our minds explode then
we'll talk have a good one everybody